so marie so alex wir packen heute
kostenloses polit chaos
das ist komisch wir machen wir dann
kostenlose produkte auf okay jetzt weiß
ich wo ich bestellen aber ich kann dich
nicht mehr zurückschrecken
[Musik]
hey was geht ab und herzlich willkommen
zu einem biotop natürlich euch jetzt gut
ich habe heute marie wieder dabei das
passiert ja irgendwie manchmal jetzt
öfter in letzter zeit dass du auch mit
dabei ist werden uns heute hier
zusammengefunden um nach sehr langer
zeit ich habe es öfter mal gelesen dass
ich doch mal bitte wieder alex testet
zehn kostenlose produkte produkte von
ruhig gestellt wo man nun den versand
bezahlen muss die sind dort mit
kostenlos deklariert meistens ist es der
größte schrott hin und wieder hatten wir
auch schon in sachen wo man sagen kann
okay ganz lustig kann man sich geben und
ja vielleicht berechtigt sondern wir
nicht schon mal dabei
ich glaube also im video was sony aber
das gute ist auch heute wieder ich habe
das nicht selber gestellt ich weiß nicht
was da drin ist was hat alles der
mitarbeiter von uns sozusagen gestellt
ja das ist auf jeden fall sehr nice ich
bin noch gespannt hat gespannt wie ein
flitzebogen preis einfach aufpassen dass
man sich hier ein tipp okay
hier siehst ja das ist hier ganz
ausgemacht hat dann geht es einfach hier
zwischen und christian hier einmal auf
und es ist richtig was kosten auf jeden
fall noch mal eine chance nochmal
eingepackt und nochmal eigentlich passt
was ist das denn
hier haben wir alter ich hab da kannst
dein handy aufladen oder da kann man
sein handy reinschieben wireless
charging fürs auto fürs auto ist ja
kummer und das kannst du hier reinkommen
und dann kommt ostendorf achten muss
wahrscheinlich einstecken
durchgehend naja du musst das im auto
ein stück dann müssen wir kurz hier
ausprobieren so ich weiß eigentlich
sollte man nur china ware nicht hier
anschließen aber mein laptop
deswegen ist es kein problem damit sorgt
dann müsst ihr auch ein iphone warten
oder ja genauso h gut das ist es um
sagna und scheint ja gut dass ich guck
dir das ding man ja was funktioniert
trotzdem gut lesbar haha ja aber das
ding ist schon von der quali her sehr
billig muss man also ich weiß dass das
hat auch die ernten so aufgemacht
elektron ist meint auch komische
geräusche
naja ok muss ich sagen so als erstes
produkt kosten und kann man nicht mehr
kann oder an also wirklich von mir ganz
neuen von zehn punkte über dem
jahresanfang und leuchtet noch ein
bisschen blau ok deutsche kommen wir
weiter zum nächsten produkt ihr könnt
ihr auch mal in die kommentare schreiben
was euch am besten gefällt
auch die meist bewegt sich immer und
woher weiß man wenn man jetzt schon kann
man also für umsonst ist heftig aber
irgendwie auch nicht gerade nachhaltigen
klingt produzieren für umsonst
rauszuschlagen
es wäre auf mallorca wo das alles und
noch heute wisse man sollte willkommen
zum nächsten probier doch mal einen tag
keine bilder
das ist jetzt mal richtig muss auch
gemacht das sieht aus wie für das iphone
12 plus oder gibts ja so das ist so eine
art hot dogs sagt man doch so bewegend
wegen otto dem tier weil das stimmt ja
unter wasser gemacht
dann kannst du hier ein handy
rheinvorland jetzt meinen ich hätte mein
iphone welt los da kommt bei mir passt
dass leute nicht haben ist das jetzt
blöd
es soll das denn weiter zu sagen doch
nicht mein thema moment mal kurz ging ja
schon getrickst hierzu es ist ja egal es
ist jetzt nur erst mal als beispiel cook
und dann kannst du damit also gut wofür
hier sind ja löcher drin ich dachte man
das ist so für unterwelt runterfällt
soll ich mal runterfallen lassen
das recht ja dann macht mal richtig zu
es geht ja darum dass das tape das auch
oder oder ist das jetzt nur so ein
denkmal sind halt die frage nahe ob das
jetzt mal was sie schon sehr stylisch
aus ich hatte gedacht dass wir für
unterwasseraufnahmen das macht ja gar
keine sind iphones sind ja eh was
natürlich zumindest ist gewissen meter
ja auch hier würde ich sagen ist ganz
cool funktioniert jetzt nur der tasche
nicht mehr das ist schlecht doch
funktioniert foto was gibst du hier für
punkte ja wenn das richtige handy da
drin ist es bestimmt ganz gut so aber
ich weiß halt nicht wenn das auch für
umsonst das wirklich so ist wie es sein
sollte personal sicherheit kommen wir
zum nächsten wohnung dann will ich sagen
hier das nächste da ich erst mal auf
noch okay ich habe hier irgendwie die
vermutung es handle sich um einen
bildpunkt weil das fühlt sich so an ihr
oder aber für kleinere menschen also
vielleicht ein bier punkte chinesen drei
chinesen an ostern soll jetzt überhaupt
nicht irgendwie flüchtlinge oder sony
das ist ein
guck mal ein set für kindergeburtstag
immer und hier steht drauf an was du ja
ja ich weiß alles sieht schon schießt
aus in der auch seh ich aber weiß ich
wenn ich kinder vergessen dass wir das
sonntag sprechen
aber das weiß man bei anderen sachen mir
auch nicht so dass trainiert hat diese
partner die man hier in deutschland
kaufen kann werden wahrscheinlich auch
dort und von daher aber in der optik ist
sehr schön wenn ich mein patenkind geben
wenn ihr dieses produkt haben wollt
werde ich es jetzt verlosen wir müssen
einfach nur den kanal abonnieren eine
million freunde markiert und schon nehmt
ihr teilt ok ja auch jetzt nichts
besonderes aber kann man nicht mehr
kommt ist es okay wenn du hier dieses
papier gemacht anders ab du kommst dann
kannst du direkt auf weiß ich ja ja das
kann ich so was hat riesige luftballons
ein stern das ist schon ein stein hat
normal
die haben vielleicht das miteinander der
kleine und der große luftballons
[Musik]
dann bist du irgendwo
hast du kannst das in der hülle man kann
vielleicht ein kleines areal noch mit
dino wieser ist ein kindergeburtstag
planen sie verwenden seine mission
entdeckt das bringt aber ordentlich das
wäre ein riesen luftballons bei mir ist
total finde dich davon aber passt oft
schon hat man muss nur zu denken
das könnte ich kann das nicht auf börsen
jetzt auch so war
[Musik]
ich mag ja offensichtlich auch mit ja so
kommen wir zum nächsten produkt was
haben wir denn hier
ohne könnte guck mal die sieht so aus
wenig hatte die du mit deinem am 8
überhaupt gar nicht hätte meine mama hat
richtig zwei perlenketten
das sind aus unseren brutale kette
stehen aber ich freue mich oder die kann
er zusammen mit der kasse an finde ich
dir heute habe die übrigens immer noch
ich habe nachts musste merck hat ich
finde die kette aber eigentlich besser
als die die du mir geholt das war
nochmal dreierkette die ju - sie ist man
ihm sagt werner rau ich glaube 100 euro
so teuer alter die war kostenlos
okay leute ist nicht so dass man mir
natürlich sehr leid für alle kleine
kette ist wirklich viel viel besser
nur das ding ist ich bin solche
reinigung oder katze mal vergleichen von
der qualität nähe die ist schlecht von
der qualität ich merke ich habe nur ich
bin halt so was zu ketten an geht
einfach nicht so da bin ich nicht so
vertraut mir ich könnte jetzt nur 1000
euro könnte nicht von den 50 euro kette
oder steuerliche aber ich weiß nicht ist
das auch ein bisschen fühlt sich total
regelhaft an einer kamera
ja wir haben noch mega viel eigentlich
das ding ist was du als auch dann
anrichten
pro tag darf eigentlich wollte ich
wieder nur zehn produkte vorstellen nur
wir haben diesmal viel viel mehr ich
habe in meinem büro alleine noch 20
dinge ich weiß auch nicht was sie schon
wieder die nächste schreiben kommentare
einem must-have weil ihr könnt eine
klinik wir können einen mega vierten
geburtstag feiern mit diesen ganzen -
offen hier die haben wir die no
servierten sorgen
leute ich muss erstmal sagen bevor sich
jetzt will ich von euch aufregen dass
das wieder so viel schrott es hier es
kam alles zusammen in drei paketen also
die ganze pakete schauen was alles zu
die wohnen jetzt ein was ist das herz
von dino augen auf kirche - hier ist
auch nur müll drin
hier könne noch etwas investieren seien
und nicht auch noch guck mal noch mehr
aber ich muss sagen ich lasse mir jetzt
wirklich riesige luftballons dass sich
schon das hatte ich schon mal das ist
zwar schon ewig her aber hier ist so
konfetti drin und wenn du die loslässt
dann geht's richtig ab hier sollte das
mal zeigen lassen
na ja aber was man ihr regel ich sagen
muss alles wird ja irgendwie zusammen
gepackt
hier ist halt so tesafilm komplett rum
und ich glaube nicht dass das maschinell
gemacht werde
das wird alles von hand irgendwie
verpackt das ist nicht nur 30 anhänger
also ich glaube hier ist etwas
wertvolles drin habe ich das gefühl das
wetter da sind werden
das ist so irgendwann packt alles wäre
was richtig richtig teures und es sind
also immer noch alltag junger ca
das tut mir ein bisschen leid ich bin
jetzt davon ausgehen dass sie die auch
sachen drin haben die cool sind es hat
ja ganz gut angefangen würde ich mal
schätzen aber irgendwie ja ich habe auf
jeden fall im büro noch ein paar pakete
ich glaube ich noch ein bisschen größer
waren
das war ein flop ich glaube dieses ich
teste kostenlose produkte das ist nicht
mehr ganz es lohnt sich einfach nicht
mehr
und da war das passt auf jeden fall ganz
gut was maria hat gesagt hört das video
ist auch von wunsch weil ungefähr so
leider war nur mit und wir hoffen dass
sich loch gefallen ich kann euch
versprechen in zukunft kommt auch das
ein oder andere echte video von will ich
wieder ich habe mich auch ein bisschen
geld in die hand genommen
seid gespannt abonniert serien den kanal
viele haben sich das gewünscht dass ich
da mal wieder mehr machen soll das war
es heute haut rein